yeah
am i recording
i think so wonderful all right
all right uh there was some clits this
morning uh in webex but i think we are
um
we are on board everyone is on board i
think so
it's good to start i'm glad we can start
on time
all right uh welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
mute and ask otherwise
please use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
q a session at the end
second uh today's gdpr seminar is open
to external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally the talk today
will be
recorded and uploaded in our youtube
channel that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host dr ellis
cicerello who is an associate
professor at tu delft alice is the
founder and the head of the data
vibration and uncertainty group i'm
currently leading the mvu laboratory at
tu delft
let's join the engineering structures
department at tu delft in january 2020
previous to this position she was a
departmental lecturer in dynamics and
vibration at the oxford engineering
science department
and a career development fellow in
engineering science that
barely old colleagues from 2017 to 2019
her research interests span from
fundamental to applied research her
technical expertise covers uncertainty
quantification and machine learning
physics based modeling and dynamic
experimental
testing and
their combination
alice's research aims at developing
effective strategy strategies for
supporting decisions in
operating conditions and at the design
stage under deep uncertainties
alice is holding currently many
positions she is a hat of a
the mechanics and the physics of
structural section at tu delft and also
collaborating staff within the offshore
engineering section and vis visiting
fellow at the engineering science
department at the university of uh the
oxford
and honorary lecturer at the institute
for risk and uncertainty department of
civil engineering and industrial design
at university of liverpool
and also a member of the
organizing committee of the 10th
international conference on modern
practice in stress and vibration
analysis
and lastly the member of the
international technical committee of the
eighth
international symposium on reliability
engineering and risk
management
all right
today alice will give a talk
about uh the
very interesting topic uh which is the
interpretable explainable and
non-intrusive uncertainty propagations
through expensive to evaluate models via
ml optimization
please expect a wonderful talk from
alice and enjoy it and now without
bothered you let me pass the button to
at least by asking our usual question
what is your favorite things to do other
than research at least
um my favorite thing to do is listen to
music
while working
or walking either way what kind of music
the classics
i like terrible music
[Music]
pop music
you know
everything that you can think of but
also jazz it depends on the mood you
know it depends on the mood yes yes yes
that's how it goes okay the stage is
heroes alice
thank you so much thank you so much for
this very generous introduction and for
having me today it's actually my honor
really to be here and to see so many of
you online attending this talk um
so
what i'm gonna talk about during this
talk are actually three parts first of
all i will tell you why should we care
about the fact that we want
interpretable explainable and
unintrusive uncertainty propagation and
then i will try to describe to you which
are the most pressing challenges and
finally i will be talking to you about
how we can exploit machine learning to
select the minimum number of physics
based models to run in order to get
performance bounds
okay so without further ado i'm gonna
start making a strong case of why we
need this
so first of all i'm interested in
engineering structure in general
engineering system
and there we have performance
that we have to satisfy and that we have
to meet and of course we have
uncertainties that we have to deal with
you can imagine about the noise
vibration largeness performance of cars
and about the sun pressure level at the
drive your location you can think about
safety during uh launching you can think
about cost in drilling application and
you can think of other performance
metric like optical data accuracy and
when we think about this kind of
performance we have to think about the
things that we know and we don't know
and of course we have to remember that
if we consider just a car just to drill
into just a satellite their response
will be different because of
uncertainties and this uncertainties may
come from inner and variability or may
come up by the fact that we don't know
everything about it or we don't know all
the things that we need for our physics
physics-based model
so uncertainty is very important
and if we think about the models that we
usually run in engineering we think
about
deterministic models and then how to
implement uncertainties but why is this
important
because we have to make this decision
and under uncertainties and you can
think about it this very simply you can
think about the effect of uncertainties
and then how it will influence
performance metric so you see on the
right on the x-axis uncertainty is going
from low to high and on the y-axis the
influence on performance metric and what
we can see immediately is that if you
are in the low uncertainty range but the
influence is also low we should not
worry we can still use pretty much a
deterministic model and even if the
uncertainty is very high but we are
still seeing no influence of those
uncertain parameters on our performance
imprisia we can still use a
deterministic model however the region
in which we should not worry is actually
really small and most of the time we are
actually in this top corner in which you
are worrying and we are worrying for two
reasons because in principle if we are
in the region in which there is an eye
influence on the performance metric of
uncertainties we rather want to change
the design or we want to gather more
information and in the case then we want
to quantify these uncertainties we want
to see
because maybe we cannot change the
design
and most of the time we are in this top
part and now we want to select design
the satisfied performance matrix
okay but where are these uncertainties
coming from i told you generally that
can be aliataric or epistemic
in principle we can think about two
things we usually use a physics-based
model and therefore we can have
uncertainty related to the computational
model itself but also we have the inputs
of the computational model
so if we think about the computational
model it depends on the complexity of
the physics that we are currently
embedding but also the knowledge on the
model parameters so the input parameters
that we are giving
of course then if we think about the
inputs we will have the loading
condition and the manufacturing
variability the loading will arise
because we will have varying
environmental condition but also
operating conditions and similarly with
manufacturing variability
we want to function in variability there
are different things that we should
think about and these are for structural
engineering for instance geometric
damping material properties the joint
details and the boundary condition so in
a nutshell those are the things that we
worry about
but now why do we need something that is
interpretable and explainable well if we
have to make decision
making basically and we have to make
decision based on uncertainties then we
need to be able to explain how we did
that prediction
and actually we have to interpret that
and we have to be able to communicate
the prediction to support
decision-making
so interpretability and explainability
becomes extremely important
and there's something that is almost
hidden inside that
in a way if we are able to interpret our
prediction was made we will be able to
if we think about something that is
explainable instead we will be thinking
about the fact that the prediction must
be in principle and actually capable of
quantifying what we don't know
now if we think of the importance of
being interpretable is because people
will trust more something that they will
understand if we have a physics-based
model they understand how the
physics-based model was selected then
there would be more confidence
but of course there is another very
important part there is expandability at
the end we stay in the decision hard
people and critical decisions that need
to be presented in a format that is
understandable by humans
okay
so what is the overall goal then what
does it mean having an interpretable ex
an intrusive uncertainty quantification
approach
well what we would like to do is to form
we would like to basically consider a
physics-based model that is as detailed
as possible every information that we
have everything that we know we would
like to be included and then we will use
funny talent boundary element and
expenses to evaluate models
and then what we would like to do
is basically not apply any modification
or simplification to the physics
everything that we know we would like to
retain we would like to account for
uncertainties taking all the information
that we have available
and then look at the response matrix
and of course
would be to say okay i want to
understand the performance
using a few evaluations as possible and
having these results that i can
interpret and explain
but of course there are challenges in
doing that and i'm going to now describe
to you which are the challenges since
trying to do this and why machine
learning is actually can be our friend
in this and helping us
enabling to do this kind of analysis
so imagine that we have to select the
best performance design and we are using
a deterministic model
which are a structural system in this
case the transmission system and we run
a physic-based model a
and we evaluate a response metric now we
have a different design let's call it
big and then we run the visit-based
model we have different competing
designs we have a zed of them
great what we want to do is to select
the best performance design and it's the
one that of course minimize a
performance metric
however what happened is that
this design can be obtained by
parameterizing or considering completely
different
competing design
now what if we consider uncertainties if
we just take design a so that's what
you did
in design a then we will have to include
uncertainties for each
realization of the uncertain variable we
will have to run different physics model
and then we will have to evaluate the
performance metric but now this
performance metric will depend on the
fact that we have uncertainties
what is happening though is that pretty
quickly we are increasing the
computational cost we are not just
looking at design a we are looking now
uh i mean a designer and the uncertain
designer and then we'll have to do it
for design b designs it
and
that it can be very very challenging and
of course their performance battery will
change as well
okay so
what does it end uh apologies sometimes
there are new people arriving so my
screen
uh that's this one apologies for that
please ignore that i can take care of
that yeah thank you so much uh so let's
imagine that we now are in the design
uncertainty space and again i call this
design of engineering system in general
but is basically thing that you can use
also for material for anything of design
so imagine that you have competing
design solution the 1d2 d3dm
and and then you have the uncertainties
basically and of course for each
realization you're going to have all of
this different domain and the problem is
that you don't want just to be for an
uncertain variable along the
oblique line or being in one of the
horizontal lines you would like to
evaluate all these models
and of course this is very much
time-consuming but you also have to
think about four different problems
so the first problem
the first problem is how do we describe
uncertainties i don't do which were the
uncertainties i haven't yet told you how
we're going to describe them
and
in principle you can have two different
type of uncertainties
parametric uncertainty is a
non-parametric uncertainties
what does it mean parametric means you
take your father and mother for instance
the one of the guard that was showing
and you assume that you know you have
some information about the physical
parameters and you describe that with
probability density function then what
you want to do is propagate the
uncertainties for instance with
montenegro and you want to compute the
effect on the response in this case the
effects would be
done captured by statistics of the
response confidence variable confidence
levels and reliability
non-parametric approach is something
different what is saying is that you
don't need to specify the parameters
that are uncertain but you can take
uncertainties to an eye level and these
are approaches that are used in vipre
acoustic especially for statistical
energy analysis around the matrix theory
and they enabled you to reduce
significantly the computational cost but
they work under some assumption
okay so if we say that we then have to
choose parametric because we are in the
domain in which parametric is the only
way forward then we have to account for
two type of description probabilistic
and non-probabilistic what do i mean by
that probabilistic means that we have
information about some input parameters
with a probability density function
non-probabilistic means that we have
just after a lower bound a region in
which the parameters will actually leave
okay and now what's the catch well
if you choose a certain uncertain
description you have to then
use a certain uncertain problem
if it is probabilistic you can use monte
carlo form and other approaches if it is
non-probabilistic there are other
techniques that are well established and
of course you can be in the case in
which you have combined description
now the interesting thing is that it is
not only the propagation that is
changing but also the results how you
describe the output so if you have
probabilistic description your results
would be statistics confidence level
reliability and i'm assuming many of you
are very familiar with those
and we don't probably see there is the
bounce on the responses that we are
interested in and if it is combined then
we look at the bounds on statistical
results
now
as i told you what happened though is
that if we change the description and we
change the output also the magic the
performance metric will change
now if you imagine that we have a
probabilistic description we will have
at the end for each design solution
appropriate density function and each
curve will
represent the response variable of
interest
then we will look for instance of what's
the probability of exceeding a certain
threshold and we will look for the
solution that actually minimize the
probability of failure that's pretty
straightforward that's what we most of
the time do
but most of the time we have a problem
we don't have enough information to
define a probability function
we actually have most of the time just
tolerance value plus minus for instance
the young modulus plus value plus plus
or minus
that
thickness of something or maybe you ask
an expert and they can give you
information in terms of plus minus
what the variable will take value
there could be also other reason to use
this sort of found in the description
because maybe you know that there are
some physics based limits and so you
know that the variable cannot take
certain uh values passively
so if before we add a probability
density function
now what is happening
we don't know enough not knowing enough
means that we may change the probability
function as input
but that performance is strongly
dependent on the pdf
now another thing that is very important
to say is that an interval a tolerance
volume is not a uniform pdf
and by that i mean that if we say there
is a uniform pdf we will be adding
information because knowledge value
within the interval and it has an equal
probability of occurring and there will
be also very low probability of random
sampling at the bounce and it may be
there at the bottom we have some
information imagine this in the
multi-space of course as well
okay
so this is the fourth problem that i was
trying to describe
and i told you that there's something
about the metrics that is changing
because now we have bounded we don't
have any longer pdf but we have boundary
descriptions so for design a design b
design zap we do the full propagation
and we get this
and now the medical interest is changing
because this can be the minimum of the
upper bound or of the lower bond
okay but then how do we handle this how
do we have the the fact that we have to
take into account uncertainties and how
do we reduce the number of simulation if
we want to then to use it to compare
design
now let's assume that you have a
detailed deterministic model of the
engineering system
if you have intervals that will be given
as a new
get an uncertain output variable that
depends on this input parameter
what it means is that you will have each
of these gray curves there is one
realization and then maybe your
performance assessment is
is the response within the bounds these
blue dots that are shown in the figure
if it is then i'm satisfied with that if
it is not
then that's not the design that i'm
gonna use
okay
what's the main problem that in
principle we should calculate our
response variable
for every single value of b
and this is remembering that we have an
expensive to evaluate model behind it
so most of the time we will be able to
calculate the response a few points but
not exactly at every point or we will
not be able to run any way a model of
those points
and what makes things even more
complicated
in case of interval is that
we don't have this expensive revolving
model there is a non-monotonic response
which means that the upper and lower
bounds of the response will not happen
at the outer lower bound of the
variables
we will have also
many uncertainties and we have usually
especially in engineering a limited
computational budget so how do we handle
this how do we can we solve this problem
and again
this is what machine learning can help
us
and helping us in this case not by
looking at data that are coming from
measurements but actually in a physics
based model that we can
really take advantage of
okay so
just to give you a quick overview at the
moment what we do do in this case
is to look at vertex method so we just
look at the upper lower bound we combine
them
and then we can look at the sub interval
method and of course there are lots of
global search algorithms it's becoming
another lower bound optimization problem
of course and depending on the
assumption that you make you can have
different solutions
if you think about the global search
algorithm these are the most
used they require a reliable pseudonym
model but there are problems with
building the surrogate models
imagine that you have to create this
surface right and you want to create the
surface because then you want to build
this surrogate model to speed up
computation
now when you have to use basically this
observation of the surrogate model you
have
many techniques that you can use
you can use polynomial models you can
use calcium process artificial
neural network support vector machine so
there are many ways in which we can
handle this problem
however what is happening is that when
we try to build the surrogate model we
have to remember
what we have
so we want to have few simulation runs
so let's imagine that we can run all the
four full simulation of a multiphysics
problem in which we have everything that
we care about
and now we have our response w
calculated uh k1 3
5 and k upper bar so four points okay
now
approximation we can say okay looks like
this actually we look at our model we
make it more complex more complex more
complex and then basically what we see
there on the left is our approximation
which is for points
but of course our approximation just for
points
uh may not be represented because we
don't have enough information about what
was happening what you see to the right
in fact are the 330 model evaluation so
the black cure we spoke we don't know
and is what happened if we run 330 times
models
now this is now telling us something uh
from what we have to the left indeed we
will need information and more data but
of course what is happening is that when
we think about the data we have to think
about
which is the right surrogate model are
the underthinking or overfitting the
problem how to do the ipad parameters
chart the conversion criteria how to
select different points and actually
that's where we are coming in with this
approach that i'm finally going to
present to you in which we say
we find basically a way to select the
minimum number of simulation that you
need in order to get the upper a lower
bound what i mean by upper and lower
bound in this case are these flat cross
studies here and this blue cross there
so this is the upper this is the lower
and that's the only thing that we have
now we don't care about getting a pretty
responsive face what we care about is
getting accurately the maximum and the
minimum of the performance
okay
so what is the proposed proposed
strategy in a nutshell
and where is machine learning coming in
let's say that we have this interval as
input parameters
and we just run a few complex model
simulations say four or five
then we built a responsive place that
actually includes the uncertainties but
this uncertainty is not coming from the
interval is an uncertainties coming from
the fact that we haven't run the
simulation
and then what we want to do is to use
function for selecting which is the
neurons that we should actually consider
in order to improve
the maximum and minimum prediction
and then we can do this derivatively and
of course we can obtain for instance the
maximum or the minimum of the response
but we don't stop there we want to also
quantify which is the remaining
uncertainties that is coming from the
fact that we haven't run all the
simulation and we want also to figure
out basically a way to assess
if the bounds that we get are
satisfactory
so basically the old goal is to say
which is the minimum number of
simulations that we need of our
physics-based model that we can consider
as a black box because it's sitting you
know behind
this machine learning algorithm and what
we're trying to do is to get the maximum
minimum of the response but also
quantify the uncertainties caused by not
having run all these inductions
okay so if so far things make sense and
i hope that this
step-by-step introduction helped you now
we can dive in on capture technique
and the big shift we have to do is to go
from a continuous function of the
response to a discrete respirance
function
and account for the fact that we really
don't know the response those points in
which we ever run the simulation
we cannot even guess
so what can we do then there
we can take our response function and
call let's call it now w vector and we
can take the response of b1 b2 bm
whichever is the combination of the b
vector there is uncertain parameters
and now we account for the fact that at
some point we have around the simulation
now what we can say
is that if we ever run the simulation so
if we don't have the simulation results
w a b something
then that is going to be uncertain and
it's a gaussian random value
now what this means is that at the end
we will have a collection of gaussian
random variables
so at every point let's imagine that we
didn't run any simulation at every point
we have a gaussian random variable the
collection of these gaussian random
variables is a gaussian process
this is now enabling us to move
into a section in which we can leverage
the physics and using machine learning
to select simulation
how does this work we take this w vector
and we divide it in two parts
and the first part are the noise free
observation these are our simulation we
run them we know the results
and then
the w star k there are all the points in
which we want to predict our response so
those are functionality session in which
we haven't done the simulation so when
there is this
little person here thinking and what we
want to do is to get the response there
okay
so what we can do then is to use a gp
regression model there is this
non-parametric approach
okay how does it work basically we take
the noise free observation and the
function that we want to predict
and we say the jointly they have a
cancer distribution now calcium
processes regression but they've been
around for a very long time there's a
very great book written by rasmussen and
williams so you should definitely go
there for finding out more about it
and basically what we are saying is that
we have
mean and we have to define what is
called the variance because it's a
gaussian distribution we need two
moments and of course we can talk about
the covariance matrix and the way in
which we describe the covariance matrix
for gaussian process
is by using what is called a kernel
function
so most of the time we say for the mean
in the prior assumption that is zero b
and then we make an assumption though a
strong assumption sometimes on the
kernel function
and that in fact encodes
the smoothness of the response function
and basically what it does is that it
gives you a value that says how similar
are the response obtained on similar
return similarities basically between
the two points
now this is the key assumption that we
have to make and there are several that
you can use and sometimes when you don't
know anything there are also kernel
functions that you you can you can use
and again this kernel function look at
that smoothness of the response that you
haven't run
but what's the powerful of this because
we are dealing with gaussian processes
done by conditioning we can calculate
basically the expression in cross form
of what is the probability of basically
observing
a certain value w star
now this is by conditioning that we
obtain this and it's basically a
predictive marginal um
sorry a predictive distribution but we
can also look specifically of what we
care about
there is the predictive mean and
variance
at each stats point
again this test point is where we ever
run the simulation
and
again if you look at the book in
gaussian process you will find this
expression they were there simple
calculation you can do it by end
and what i'm going to show you in the
next slide is just an example or how we
can use them
so let's imagine that we have this
function here and basically it's our
unknown true response
it will take 330 simulation to obtain it
if we take just the upper and lower
bound of the response we will actually
underestimating and overestimating the
upper and lower bound as you can see
here because the upper bound is here and
the lower bound is there
great
so what do we do with the gaussian
process
let's say that we select three points
only and this is our training data set
we use this expression to obtain the red
line there is the mean and then we have
this gray area there is the two sigma
that is the valence
okay
so the confidence bounds to be precise
now of course the more red dots we will
add
the better the approximation of the
response would be
but to be honest with you we don't care
about that because we we can run only
two simulation so what do we do
we don't need to have an accurate
surrogate model for every single body of
k but we can look locally
and something for those of you that are
very interested in gaussian processes
um these are the parameters that were
used and of course when you have the
gaussian process depending on the kernel
that you choose you will have also to
tune the either parameter
okay
so
this is our gaussian process but now how
do we get better how can we select which
is the next point the next red dots that
will enable us to get as fast as
possible to the maximum volume
so
the way in which we do this is to
exploit what is called paisan
optimization
and the patient optimization has been
around for a long time there are some
you can find some
in this reference
some brilliant reviews about what has
been happening
but basically what we're trying to do is
to exploit this position of transaction
and to add some flavor to it to make
sure that it works for what we care
about
so
our goal is to look at the next
simulation and i'll encourage you to
focus on only the red vertical line
remember we denote that black function
then we require 330 full simulation we
don't want to do that we have only three
at the beginning and we have the red
curve and the there is the approximation
the mean approximation and the vertical
line there is where
now our variation optimization is
telling us to go and sample again so
it's very close to the first point
then we go
and we get that point and we get this
green box that you see here
and we ask again automatically of course
to go and look for the next point
in which we should sample
and will give us basically this other
point here this green point there
okay so we run the simulation so
basically it is telling us so we have at
the moment these red points in the green
and it's telling us to sample here we
sample that and that is telling us
automatically iteratively where to get
the next point
now remember we don't know anything
about the system and if this is
happening automatically in the
background
until we reach a certain iteration
number so how did the code decide this
how did position optimization work in
the background
what was doing was using what is called
an acquisition function that is telling
us where to acquire the next point where
to get the next simulation in this case
forgetting the max
okay how does it work it takes the
observation that we have up to the point
and again observation are results from
physics based simulation our w0 and
basically say okay from those i can look
at the marks so for instance in this
case here the max will be this point
okay this is the maximum observation
that we have up to the point
now what we can do is to look at
improvement
improvement means can we
improve with respect to the current
maximum
can we have basically our function to be
greater than these months if so we will
improve otherwise we want because we are
looking just at the max
now there are different ways of doing
that but basically the gist of it is the
following so if you define improvement
in this way now we want to talk about
probability of improvement
and these are deterministic
values that you got but this is coming
actually from the model you've just
approximated we just took our w
and we say okay wait we can use account
some process
so if this is a gaussian process then
this is a normal distribution what it
means is that we can then again very
easily go through it and calculate the
probability of improvement our
probability is for us to improve and
it's expressed in this way and again
it's a gaussian distribution
but also what we can look at is what is
called expected improvement
and what this function will do is
actually balance worries
that we know and what we want to explore
so if we know something we say that we
exploit what we know and if we want to
go farther away we say that we explore
now the probability of improvement is
one of those acquisition functions that
actually uses
mostly what we know already while
expected improvement is very good at
balancing what we know and what we want
to explore
okay
so
perfect
so now the problem is that i explained
to you what's happening in the
background how to select the next point
simulation but when do we stop how do we
select when we say enough those are
enough simulation again we don't know
the black curve so we cannot really say
okay now we stop
okay
so in principle let's say that we have
an iteration number zero these points
that have been suggested again let's
focus on the vertical red lines
then we get
this point and we now say been told to
sample here and we can look at iteration
four but we can look also in direction
seven i mean they both look pretty good
and they get actually pretty quickly
onto the maximum
but how do we stop so one way to stop
obviously is to say i have this in this
much simulation and so then i need to
stop
but of course there's another criterion
that can be used and this criterion is
to say which is actually a value on the
acquisition function that is reached and
one of these is usually to say which is
the maximum value the acquisition
function will take if it is below a
certain value so for instance in this
case 10 to the minus 2 for the expected
improvement then we say we stop
okay
so
if we say so then we can actually stop
our simulation but how do we know if the
bounds are satisfactory well i can start
writing a question for you and i can go
through them
but probably will not be very helpful
but what i can tell you is that one way
to do that and that's where we also
contributed was to say how far are we
going
so
with our acquisition function where is
the acquisition function suggesting us
to take the next point and how far is
respect to the current outcome
another metric that you can think of
actually saying look if you look at the
current maximum minimum of the
observations which means the simulation
that you run how far are they from the
current hotel
and if you look at these two types of
conditions that we have done then
basically what we can say is that if
they are not met
we actually have to run more simulation
we haven't got there we haven't got to
the actual bonds
and
this can help us reduce potentially
large inaccuracies and i'm going to show
you in a few minutes an example for that
but just to give you then i know that i
was giving many inputs many information
but how does it really work
so imagine that you have your physics
place model you have these uncertainties
and you start selecting just few
simulations you run
then what you do is that you build a gpa
regression model and you use every
single data that you add
then you check if you need to stop
simulation it can be that you're already
getting the maximum for instance
and then you select in case the stopping
criteria is not satisfied you select one
simulation needed
to run for improving the upper bound
you run the simulation and you have a
new training data set that now contains
the point that you had at the beginning
plus this one and then you go back and
you build the chip aggression model and
again you go in a loop so it's an
iterative theoretical
once you then get the stopping criteria
you actually get out from this group and
you get the response but also you check
the matrix
now
in a very by using optimization fashion
you can do this by considering the upper
bound separately from the lower bound
and we can do we can start with the same
gpu at the beginning but then we will
have two different uh enhanced training
data set for the upper bound and the
lower bound
what we argued is that it could be
actually in some cases and we have
observed that it could be a better idea
to combine this information so you start
with some initial simulation but when
you select the upper bound at the lower
bound you select both on the same gpu
regression model and then you enhance
the training data set not just with one
simulation more but with two together
and then you go back and as a result
when you stop you will get the upper and
lower bound response
okay
so
what is happening now i was talking
about interval and how to use machine
learning to that interval but i ended up
talking about probability so how is this
really working and now is can this be
easily communicated to engineering again
we want to uh actually being having an
approach that is explainable and hope
that i was able uh to actually explain
it to you and interpret that also
what is happening so can we actually uh
what can we do with this so we were
interested in the maximum and minimum of
the response
and of course the easiest way to see is
that now this approach enabled us to
select in a clever way points in which
we will know that we are going to
improve our maximum minimum prediction
so we're just going to transfer this
deterministic observation that's one way
to look at it
the other one instead say
wait but at each point so say here for
instance this is our current maximum
of the response very close to the green
we're gonna have
not only the mean prediction there is
this spread curve but we're going to
have also a variance prediction
confidence balance so what we can do
then is to say that the upper bound the
lower bound are themselves
interval variables and then we say which
is the actual upper bound is going to be
the mean
plus the uncertainty
and the lower bound instead is going to
be defined in this way
if we say so what is happening is that
now we are always going to be able to
over predict the upper bound with
respect to the current simulation
results that we have
and we will always be able to
underpredict the lower bound
and what is this
what does this mean is that we are
always going to be better than the
actual physic based information that we
have and we will be always overconfident
with respect to the physics based
simulation
not necessarily with the true response
that's why the metrics are so important
okay
so
i i show you how the procedure works but
how does it work if we consider two
separate enhanced training data set so
this method a
if you look at the lower bound and we
try to calculate the first the minimum
we start with three points that's where
the question function is telling us to
go then at the direction five is
actually going in the right direction
iteration number 10
we're pretty much done if we look at the
upper bound then we can look similarly
at them iteration 0 5 and 10. and you
can see how it is going but also i was
exploring other points that were far
away from the max just to make sure that
things were going the right way
in order to do that we needed so instead
of calculating 330 simulation we just
needed 20 of them three initial 12 for
the lower bound seven for the upper
bound and what we did to stop was saying
if the position function that was
expected improvement is below this 10 to
the minus two then we will start
so that's how the code decide to stop
and again 20 simulation versus 330.
again the results that we will get are
going to be physics based
okay
and then if we instead consider this
combined approach in which we account
for the same gpu but we look for the
maximum minimum these are actually all
the results that i've been showing to
you up to now because up to now is
always showing to you figures in which
we have this red and this blue and again
the red is telling us where the position
function wants us to go to improve the
max but the blue is telling us where the
position function wants us to improve
the mean
so in this case it was saying we start
from these three points you should look
at here you should look at this for the
next point we run the simulation and
then we are here and there again the
acquisition function apologies
uh
selects that and is building
the response what you can notice
from this
is that because we are at the same time
looking for the max and the minimum
independently we are also getting for
free a better approximation of the
entire response surface
and in this case in fact we are able to
reach
to uh
basically
to reach the tolerance on the position
function of the expected improvement in
only 14 simulation
so in this case we reduce even more the
number of simulations that we needed in
order to get the response
now just to give you some information
because i'm sure that many of you will
wonder this i started with three points
what if i was having as a starting point
six points nine points 12 points 15 volt
is kept better
and what you see there is that other
number of simulation for initial
training data set
what you see here is the percentage
error in the left is for the lower bound
and in the right is for the upper bound
and what you can notice is that not
necessarily
improving or including more points in
the initial trading dataset will give
you better upper bound or lower power
not for metadata not for method being
the reason is pretty simple because uh
with better the a and b what you're
trying to do is to select the point that
matter the most
while if you just in this case we do
equally spaced data points those
information give us maybe a better um a
better response surprise but not
necessarily
a better approximation of the maximum or
the mean
okay and just to give you another sense
that was a very simple you know bonding
case i can show you pretty picture
that's nice but if we go higher uh in
dimensions so in this case we had a
physic-based model it was taking couple
of hours to run
and we will have four uncertain
parameters to consider and this is a
typical uh a viper houston problem that
is found uh to provide some insight in
the structural uh acoustic
domain
so
what i just wanted to point out to you
are what we did for validation we use
this sub-interval method and we have to
run
these large voltages this very large
number of simulation
if we use just the upper lower bound we
need to just run this now this is our
let's say true response
and if you look at what happens if we
just take the upper and lower bound of
the variable i mean for one it's gonna
be okay we're gonna get zero percent
before the other one instead we got an
error that is 56 percent we show this
because sometimes a bound can happen
also at the upper lower bound and it's
important to remember
and then what we can show to you is what
happened with approach a and approach b
for the upper and lower bound and what
you can see here i don't know what is
happening sometimes
is
things are appearing apologies for this
um
but if we look at approach a for the
lower bounds we will need just 12
simulation if we look at approach p for
the lower bound we will need this at 29
but for approach a we actually spot on
on the value and in fact we get zero
error percentage for approach b instead
we have an error what is important to
notice
is that when we get this value we also
get an uncertainty so in a way we have a
flag we have something that is telling
us look that is actually not the right
value and actually if we look at the
observer of the values that we have
already run we add this value there
okay so then if we look at the upper
bound of the response
we can do a similar analysis we can use
approach 8 or approach t remember
approach p for lower bound and upper
bound are actually happening
simultaneously this is just for
simplicity shown in this way
but in order to get to get a good
approximate solution we will need to run
this many analysis with approach a much
lower with approach b
but you can see here that we still have
a small error and in principle here we
will see that the uncertainty is zero
however you can see
that there are things here that are
different so it's a small variation in
the position and actually
most of the condition will not be met
and in fact for the lower bound we will
need to run one only additional
simulation and also for this case we
will be actually given
uh
in this case exact values because we get
the upper lower bound but we will be
flagged there is a small variation again
the metrics do not know which is the
percentage ever they are based on where
their position function is telling us to
go and where is the prediction of our
bound with respect to what we have
evaluated up to the point
okay so again we have been discussed
this problem in speaker we have lots of
uncertainties what happen if we change
the initial training data set if we look
at 8 9 16 25 you can see again that the
number of points do not necessarily give
us
uh a better error i mean reducing error
so we don't reduce the error
in the prediction
okay so this concludes my presentation
and what i showed you are two
non-intrusive approaches
and they drastically reduce the number
of brands required and they enable us to
also quantify the remaining uncertainty
and the good things about this is that
they are interpretable explainable and
if we think about interpretable we have
behind it an expenses to evaluate
basic space model there is other
platforms
we use calcium process to impact what we
know and what we don't know what we know
are this noisy observation and what we
don't know is actually a partial you
know actually we can say is the kernel
so we can embed also the user knowledge
we also uh enable them to select
simulations that are justified between
the dot are exploiting what we have and
exploring the domain that is uncertain
and we get abundant description
of the response bounds and we have
metrics that verify if these bonds are
satisfactory i know the good things and
i would like to stress this again is
that we are always going to be
overpredicting the upper bound and under
predict the lower bound with respect to
the current observation
of course you know it's not that we
solve everything it's not that uh the
world is perfect now there are still
many challenges in the field
and uh one of them is related to the gp
that is very robust up to 20 dimension
and and therefore how then you combine
mixed type of variables if you
appropriate c function and intervals
how you combine them with experimental
data and if you have continuous and
discrete variable
how can you choose better acquisition
function and many more
so without further ado i would like to
thank all the people that worked with me
and in particular philippe junta that
actually was my collaborator for this
favor you can find
all the data that i showed to you in
this paper there is open access
so thank you so much and i will be
extremely happy to take any question you
may have
thank you thank you
thank you so much
alice for the wonderful talk we do have
a
two questions posted in the q a
in chat room
the first question is from david
dave brown
he asked how does this system work with
multiple dynamic models
all examples the engine generates
different
talks at various rpms and there are
competing concerns of heat generation
and fuel economy the designer needs to
not only evaluate their designs but
review options to ensure that the best
choices are made in
selecting among the various design
options in short
can this be used to do uh predictability
of the best more than one of the
balanced options in the optimization
it principally can
also uh
if you take just one design it can tell
you for that design which would be the
upper bound the lower bound performance
of course if you don't want to select
design it depends also how you define
each design
are they parameterized are they discrete
variables that they can they be seen as
discrete variables something categories
it's a continuous parameter space
so in principle it can be but it really
then is dependent on the problem
that we have attempted
but everything that is in the physics
behind will stay as it is
um i don't know if this answer uh
the question
maybe i think it does okay
dave you wanna
okay let's move on to the next question
now the second question is from rob
hayes from nc state
yes the upper bound points did not
appear
okay so he's talking about slide 33 by
the way
there um so he asked the upper bound
points did not appear
equivalent to the lower bound points
being fitted in that
the upper bound fits
enjoyed data at the corner locations
where the derivative is discontinuous um
can you explain whether this is correct
yes so okay um
[Music]
so if i understood well the question
there was some problem with the audio so
apologies in case i didn't
it's about the upper bound being uh this
sort of smooth value
while the lower bound being as uh very a
very basically uh sharp corner let's put
it this way
now
the thing is that we are seeing this
this is to be honest with you what it's
behind it if you want to know it's a
single degrees of freedom
so it's a very simple model and because
of the resonance you see this kind of
effect and it's driven out in the time
domain investing if we are looking at
the peak in the time domain and what you
see there um it's something that can
happen and we chose this case study
because it was also very complex
and the kernel function that we have is
not the one that accounts for the fact
that we have sharp
corner or smooth corner is actually the
one that says okay you know nothing so
what do
so in principle if we
choose or if we knew already from the
beginning what was this behavior we
could have tuned this pattern now if you
look
at at the top
we start with these three dots and then
the blue is actually telling us where to
go next and you can see that that
iteration 5 is learning where to go and
then it's actually
still going to the right because he's
understanding that he's
going low
but then he figures out that has to go
back so in this way then he's able to go
back to the this sharp corner
and similarly what you see instead below
is that you start climbing and at
direction five we are actually almost at
the top but then
because there is so much uncertainties
in the rest of the domain he actually
pushes
uh to the rest of the domain
uh i hope that if i understood correct
answer the results were uh
sorry if i understood correctly the
question i understood that i gave the
right answer or maybe we can talk about
this soft line if uh yeah that sounds
great
all right the next question is from
shouting um
she has a question about slice 35 and 38
yes
and she asked
how to interpret
the needed number of data points
is d9
yes
um
yes so
so basically what you see here is d3d60
90 12 d15
are the initial training datasets so we
basically take this interval and we say
okay do we take just three points do we
take six points so we take the interval
and we divide it
to get six points out of it we divide to
get nine points and of course these are
equally spaced another point so there's
nothing fancy behind that
and what we wanted to try to see was
that if we added more points and of
course we could have done it you know by
randomly uh
selecting points as well but we wanted
to have some control
would we by adding more points will we
get better results so what this is
telling us is that for d3 in order to
get
to the accuracy level on the expected
improvement we needed 17 simulation for
the lower bound
and actually in this case apologies for
approach b
and then if we look at this is that we
will need 20 simulation in total so this
is looking at the lower bound an upper
bound combined and in fact is what i
showed you earlier when i say you know
you will need just plenty of those
and then for the other one is that we
need a plus and this is the results that
you see here
and if we add d6 you can see that it's
going lower but what i wanted to show
you then was not just the number of
simulations the fact that the
data that
satisfied the expected improvement was
different but also that the percentage
error
is actually changing and in fact
even if you have a larger number of
simulation and you have a large number
of data set you can still get an error
that was actually uh
bigger than the other one
so this is how to interpret this graph
or not they contain lots of information
but yeah this is the total number of
simulations for each of these then we
look at the error by comparing the
actual bounds
with the
boundaries gonna be predicted and you
can see that anyway in terms of
percentage there are very small
differences
all right thank you so much alice um
okay that was the whole i had in the
chat room um but is there any other
question from the audience then you can
admit yourself
and ask questions directly
i have a
well
question word rather comment i mean
you know i'm i'm working on the
reduction of the
project and the sampling and
the efficient sampling procedure is
really key there
as you addressed in your talk
and
this the bayesian optimization type of
the sampling method is has been applied
in reduced motor community as well
uh however as you mentioned in the at
the end since the upper bounds
is like
parameter 20 20 parameters and above
that we still need a more efficient
sampling procedure do you have any
um
insight or
um how to address that challenge you you
listed
as well yeah
[Music]
we are trying for the i dimension to
look up ways to combine different uh
calcium process
results uh so basically how to uh
we see this as a two
two type of problems of course you can
start looking at the sensitivity
analysis of the variables
uh and therefore then try to look at
those that are sensitive and use the
dimensionality from at least partially
and then look at projection scheme in
which then
you look at the different gps you
basically optimize the different gp but
the problem then
is of course combining these different
gpu in a meaningful in a meaningful way
um
so this is actually something that
we are definitely
very interested in and looking at
for us also the other part is
uh really this combined pdf and
intervals because most of the time the
inputs that you get
are for some variables at least are
described from pdf and intervals
and it is not at all clear than how you
can do that because usually these pdf of
course are not gaussian but they are
coming from different
and cd function
uh but i would be very happy to follow
up this with you and with anyone
just following the talk today uh and
discuss further about this
yeah the in terms of the gaussian
process i and the the
point of contact
at lawrence livermore who's doing the
gaussian
process research is
the one person i know is jason bernstein
i can he used
he was here but he left because i i
guess he has another meeting um i can
connect him with you and i can also
follow on uh on this matter with you as
well yeah that would be awesome
yeah yeah
right okay well with that i i think we
can conclude thank you so much for the
great talk alice uh let's thank our
speaker today um
and i hope that this talk will initiate
further collaborations between the
lawrence livermore and your group and as
well as other external uh you know the
audiences who joined us today
thank you again uh alice for the
wonderful talk thank you again for this
uh for giving me this opportunity i
really enjoyed it thank you so much yeah
you did a good job okay
thank you
bye bye have a good day